une réaction sur cette décision de
justice la chambre de l'instruction de
la cour d'appel de versailles lever le
contrôle judiciaire de benzema ce qui
ouvre son retour en équipe de france
vous n'allez pas commenter une décision
de justice et la fédération française de
football qui va qui va décider de son
retour n'est peut-être une réaction en
tant que ministre mais les réactions
c'est de boire vos propos je ne vais pas
commenter une décision de justice
donc je ne suis ni commentateurs
judiciaire ni le sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france et je ne suis pas non
plus le président de la fédération
française de football et encore moi le
responsable de la commission de
discipline de la fédération
laissons faire les choses il ya une
décision de justice qui va être
interprété comme vous l'avez dit par la
fédération française de football on à
l'euro dans moins de 100 jours on a la
chance la fédération la chance d'avoir
un bon sélectionneur j'ai la certitude
que didier deschamps fera l'équipe la
meilleure qui soit vous les faites quand
on aille le plus loin je le fais une
entière confiance de la fédération
française de foot dit c'est une première
étape vous vous réjouissez pour la
france mais j'ai pas ni à me réjouir ni
à être triste quand je vous jure mady a
besoin
il se trouve que je connais
personnellement ce joueur dans les
qualités ne sont plus à faire valoir
maintenant vous comprendrez qu'il ya une
instruction judiciaire qui est en cours
notamment drake il ya un sélectionneur
qui n'a pas envie je pense d'entendre un
ministre lui dire il faudrait
sélectionné lui mais pas lui
chacun dans ses histoires de rester à se
battre mais des ministres manuel valls
avait dit il ya pas très longtemps qu'il
était clairement pour sa non sélection
il avait pas dit de cette façon là et il
n'avait pas si ciblé le joueur il avait
parlé plus généralement de ce qui
représente l'avenir quand la france a
besoin d'eux mais le maillot tricolore
dans des épreuves sportives